placements welcome to the forge  the bladesmiths of forged in fire turned  raw steel  into epic weapons from history  history's hottest series has a new home  on youtube join judges dave baker now  why would you attack a battering ram  with a sword  i don't know but we're going to do it  anyway jameson  doug marcaida students  [Music]  along with host brady powell one of you  guys can be leaving here the champion  and we only know one way to find that  out for the sharpest cuts  the toughest strikes  catastrophic failures  [Music]  and the kill test  [Music]  it will kill  new content every week  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  subscribe now at youtube.com forged and  fire  did you bring enough for everyone  you